foreign
[Music]
er a really wonderful Christmas gift it
would make him happy
kind of present something special he
will never forget
what about someone special
what over the years ago has talked about
one person more than any other a
legendary hero who has saved countless
lives we could give him the quilt as a
present
[Music]
yeah can I help you
yes we're looking for the legendary
Kevin Bacon we're looking for the
legendary Kevin Bacon
the voice is smaller mousy I think maybe
he didn't hear you yeah
he probably got great ears I'm sorry
guys
I can't help you
[Music]
I just saw on the calendar that right
now on Earth it's almost Christmas time
we don't have time for trivialities like
Christmas but Peter's so sad about
Gamora being gone
we go to Earth they're a really
wonderful Christmas gift
happy
[Music]
something special you will never forget
what about someone special
we are looking for the legendary Kevin
Bacon we're looking for the legendary
Kevin Bacon it's your voice is smaller I
think maybe he didn't hear you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]